[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم مقتل مستوطن اسرائيليين
وجرح اخر جراء اطلاق نار في مستوطنه
كادوميم غرب نابلس اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
قالت ان مهاجما ترجل من سياره واطلق النار
على حارس مستوطنه وقتله ثم اصاب اخر قبل
ان يقتل اثناء محاولته الانسحاب من المكان
وجنوب لبنان قصف الجيش الاسرائيلي منطقه
كفر شوبا بخمسه عشره قذيفه ردا على اطلاق
صاروخين سقط حطام احدهما في الجانب
الاسرائيلي من الحدود الامم المتحده قالت
انها تحقق في تطورات وتجري اتصالات لمنع
اي تصعيد
مع استمرار الاشتباكات والقصف في السودان
وزير الخارجيه يقول ان الجيش قادر على حسم
التمرد لكنه لا يريد اتباع سياسه الارض
المحروقه في حين اكد الاتحاد الافريقي
والايجاد الالتزام بتحقيق السلام
والاستقرار الدائم في السودان
شركه متى تطلق منصتها الجديده التابعه
للانستجرام وسط تساؤلات حول ما اذا كان
بمقدورها التفوق على تويتر وذلك بعد موجه
السخط التي تسببت فيها قرارات ايلون ماسك
مؤخرا وقد انضم ملايين المشتركين بعد
ساعات قليله فقط من اطلاقها الى اللقاء